Mit 18 eine eigene Firma,
sieben Mitarbeiter
und eine 100-Stunden-Woche.
(off:) Davis ist Mitgründer
eines Start-ups.
Investor: Carsten Maschmeyer.
Sein Leben besteht jetzt
aus Business machen
und sich in der
Jungunternehmer-Bubble behaupten.
(on:) Wir wollen ja
immer besser werden, ne?
Ich hasse es zu sehen, wenn Leute
ihre Potenziale verschwenden.
Dass man einfach was
auf die Beine stellt,
was auch wirklich von Substanz ist
und auch bestehen bleibt.
Ich bin ganz ehrlich:
Als ich in seinem Alter war,
hatte ich noch keinen richtigen Plan,
was ich mit dem Leben anfangen will.
Warum macht Davis das?
Was treibt ihn an?
# Everyday I'm hustlin' ...
# Everyday I'm hustlin'.
Also, ich hatte Davis halt gefragt,
ob das nicht 'ne doofe Idee ist,
dass wir ihn halt
am Wochenende begleiten,
weil er ja da vielleicht
nicht arbeitet.
Und er hat mir halt erst mal
so knallhart ausgelacht.
Und meinte: "Ja, Max,
das ist die Start-up-Welt."
(off:) Ganz schön naiv von mir.
Heute und morgen kann ich
überall dabei sein.
Davis' Büro ist im 11. Stock,
mit Ausblick
auf die Hamburger HafenCity.
Wollt ihr was zu trinken haben?
Möchtest du was trinken? - Wasser?
(off:) Davis hat zwei Firmen
mitgegründet.
Mit einer verkauft er
digitale Visitenkarten.
Wenn man die an ein Smartphone hält,
ploppen automatisch
die Kontaktdaten auf,
und man kann sie abspeichern.
Für dieses Produkt gab's in
der TV-Show "Höhle der Löwen"
ein 50.000-Euro-Investment.
(off:) Jetzt will Davis
möglichst viele Kunden.
(on:) Ja.
(Max:) Kann ich mal
deinen Kalender sehen?
Also, ist schon ein bisschen was.
- (Max:) Ach du heilige ...
Aber das muss, das muss.
(Er lacht leicht.)
Also, du fängst an um neun Uhr.
- Immer so um neun roundabout.
(Max:) Und du planst aber wirklich
durch bis Mitternacht. - Ja, genau.
Alles Rote sind immer feste Meetings
und feste Termine.
(Max:) Es gibt also keine Aufteilung
in privat oder geschäftlich?
Das ist alles ... - Nein, es ist
immer sehr viel vermischt.
Bei mir ist es eh so ...
Ich mache ja das,
was ich jetzt mache nicht,
weil ich's nicht mag oder so,
oder weil ich davor weglaufen will.
Ich glaub,
Davis hat kein Privatleben mehr.
(lacht:) Na ja.
(off:) Davis sagt,
die ersten Großkunden
würden bald schon
sein Produkt nutzen.
(lacht:) Wer sieht sich
bei 'ner Runde FIFA?
(Rhythmische Musik)
Aber auch beim FIFA-Spielen
ist Davis voll im Businessmodus.
Zuverlässigkeit ist das A und O.
- Ja, das stimmt.
Ist das A und O.
Vor allem hast du auch einen
gewissen Ruf in der Geschäftswelt.
Den darfst du dir nicht verbauen.
Deswegen bin ich da immer pünktlich.
Ja, guck mal, das ist
schon wieder komplett ...
Dass man jetzt öffentlich sieht,
wie schlecht ich in FIFA bin,
ist echt schon 'ne Hausnummer.
- Dafür trainieren wir doch.
Genau, wir wollen ja
immer besser werden, ne?
(Lässige Musik)
(off:) Was genau Davis
für einen Lifestyle hat,
das hab ich noch nicht ganz gecheckt.
Auf seinem Insta-Kanal
zeigt er sich vor Wolkenkratzern
oder in einer der Luxussuiten
der Elbphilharmonie.
Scheint schon wichtig zu sein,
in dieser Welt zu zeigen,
dass man Erfolg hat.
Zu Montag wird das auf jeden Fall
fertig sein. Der Rest steht.
Es muss. Das muss ready sein.
- Ja.
Berkan, Mails sind
so gut wie runter, ne?
Da hab ich mit meinem Vater
drüber geredet.
Die beste Werbung,
die wir haben können B2B,
ist, wenn Unternehmen uns an
Partnerunternehmen weiterempfehlen.
So viel Potenzial.
Wie ein Spinnennetz, was sich
immer weiter spreadet.
(off:) Die Schule
hat Davis frustriert.
Er wusste oft nicht,
ob ihm das mal was bringen wird,
was er lernen soll.
Jetzt hat er ein konkretes Ziel.
Wie siehst du so die Dynamik jetzt
bei einem Gespräch wie grade?
Ich finde, es wirkt,
als wärt ihr Kumpels. - Ja.
Hast du grade was beantwortet noch
nebenher? - Da kam grad ein Anruf.
Okay. Ihr wirkt ja so wie Kumpels.
- Ja, schon.
Aber trotzdem muss man sagen,
es ist auch wichtig,
dass wenn jemand irgendwie in 'nem
Loch ist und nicht so gut performt,
dann müssen die anderen
ihn rausziehen.
Das ist wichtig, dass wenn jemand
seinen Aufgaben mal nicht nachkommt,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
dass man das auch direkt sagen kann.
Da eben Beruflich und Persönlich
immer miteinander vermischt ist,
muss man in ernsteren Situationen
gucken, dass man das trennt.
(off:) Was seine eigene Kraft
und Motivation angeht,
scheint Davis
keine Grenzen zu kennen.
Die Unternehmen, die ich
mit Berkay und Jona habe,
das ist unser Leben.
Also, dafür arbeiten wir,
dafür atmen wir, das sind wir.
So.
Da versuchst du halt auch immer,
dein Bestes zu geben.
So, und je nachdem wie du dann
auch Freizeit mit einbauen kannst ...
(Max:) Hast du denn Freizeit?
- Ja, komplett.
So, warte mal.
Berkan.
- (Max, lacht:) Ach so.
Ich werde kurz antworten.
(Max, lacht:) Super Timing.
Nee, genau. Ähm ...
Ja, auf alle Fälle.
Ähm, das ist halt ...
Na, dass ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
'ne Runde Basketball spielen gehe
oder kurz mal FIFA spiel ...
Die Leute, mit denen ich arbeite,
ich bin auch befreundet mit denen,
und das ist immer 'n Mix.
(off:) Ich merke jetzt schon:
Um Davis herum ist ständig was los.
In so Momenten wie diesen muss ich
mir immer wieder vor Augen führen,
Davis ist erst 18.
Und das finde ich schon
ziemlich beeindruckend.
Ich bin gespannt,
mit was für Freunden
sich ein Mensch wie er umgibt.
Zu denen fahren wir jetzt.
(Max, on:) Was ist
dein persönliches Ziel?
(Davis:) Mein persönliches Ziel:
Was für das Unternehmen gut ist,
ist für dich gut.
Nicht was für dich gut ist,
ist gut für das Unternehmen.
Deswegen, in erster Linie, sind meine
Ziele immer ans Unternehmen gebunden.
So, jetzt meinte der Taxifahrer,
dass er irgendwo hier steht,
aber irgendwie ...
Warte mal.
Kann das da hinten das Auto sein?
Warum ist dir das so wichtig?
Ein Hauptantrieb von mir ist einfach:
Ich hasse es zu sehen, wenn Leute
ihre Potenziale verschwenden.
Bei mir ist das 'ne Sache,
wirklich ...
Wenn ich mich zu etwas dedicate,
ähm, dann stecke ich da zu 100
Prozent drin,
und will auch mein Bestes geben.
Steht denn bei dir nur erst mal
Business machen aufm Programm
oder willst du auch mal studieren
zum Beispiel.
Momentan ist es nicht
relevant für mich,
weil ich klar weiß,
worum ich mich jetzt zu kümmern habe.
(Davis:) Also, studieren, ja, safe.
Irgendwann.
Also, ich glaub Harvard, Stanford
ist safe interessant.
Also ich sehe mich eher in so 'ner
Liga, was das Studium anbetrifft.
Wenn ich es überhaupt angehen möchte.
Ich hab nicht das beste Abi.
Ich hab einen 2,4er-Schnitt.
Ich hab nicht ordentlich gelernt,
weil ich echt viel zu tun hatte.
(off:) Krasse Ansage.
In seinem Leben ist wohl
alles möglich, glaubt er.
Davis will mir jetzt
zwei seiner Freunde
aus der Jungunternehmer-Bubble
vorstellen.
Dass wir hier irgendwie von
einem Termin zum anderen hetzen
macht ihm irgendwie gar nichts.
Wie wirkt er so auf dich, der Davis?
(Kamerafrau:) Megaentspannt.
- Ist unglaublich, ne?
(Kamerafrau:) Ich versteh's einfach
nicht. - Ich fühl mich so gestresst.
(Rhythmische Musik)
(off:) Der rechts hier
ist Philipp Kalweit.
Er ist gefragter Auftragshacker.
Eigentlich wollten wir
in seiner IT-Sicherheitsfirma drehen.
Aber weil wir da Dinge filmen
könnten, die wir nicht sollen,
stehen wir jetzt auf
dem Wolkenkratzerdach im Regen.
(on:) Wenn ihr euch trefft,
wie viel ist privat
und wie viel ist Berufstalk?
Ich glaube,
was uns stark verbindet, ist,
dass wir eine Herausforderung haben.
Wir haben Unternehmen,
sind superjung,
wollen in dem,
was wir machen, besser werden.
Das vereint uns.
Andere in unserem Alter
machen das folglich nicht.
Ich glaube, die Herausforderung
geht damit einher,
und wir ein Sprachroch benötigen,
dass man sich mal austauscht.
Weil du einfach jemanden benötigst,
der vielleicht versteht,
worum es geht
und das mitfühlen kann,
weil er in einer ähnlichen Situation
ist oder war.
Wurde euch das eigentlich
so in die Wiege gelegt,
dass ihr jetzt Unternehmer seid?
Habt ihr das auch bei den Eltern?
Also bei meinen Eltern gar nicht.
Also, die sind nicht selbstständig.
Bei mir liegt's einfach
an der sehr ehrgeizigen Erziehung.
Und das setzte sich durch.
Also, bei mir ist es so, dass ich
aus einer Unternehmerfamilie komme.
Meine Großeltern waren schon
selbstständig, meine Eltern auch.
Und bei mir hat sich das
auch irgendwie fortgeführt.
Aber dass ich so früh gegründet habe,
war auch für die neu.
(off:) Wir müssen
schnell wieder zurück ins Büro,
diesmal mit der Bahn.
David hat ein Meeting,
um an seinem Podcast zu planen.
Den macht er zusammen mit dem
TikTok-Star
Theophilus Junior Bestelmeyer.
Davis' zweite Firma lädt sich
für den Podcast Influencer ein,
auch, um von deren Reichweite
zu profitieren.
Nice!
- Boah, das ist ein geiles Bild.
Das ist ein tolles Bild.
- Kann man safe auf Insta posten.
(off:) Ich finde diese Welt schon
ganz schön abgefahren.
Und morgen soll's
noch krasser werden.
Während ich Feierabend machen kann,
bleibt Davis noch im Büro.
Alles abarbeiten, was angefallen ist.
(Nachdenkliche Musik)
Ich muss jetzt ...
Stimmt, der schickt mir einfach
drei Mails, Digga.
(Lässige Musik)
(off:) Am nächsten Tag treffe ich
Davis und seinen Kollegen
vor dem HSV-Stadion.
Sie dürfen in die VIP-Lounge.
Der IT-Unternehmer Taner Taneri
hat sie eingeladen.
Eigentlich soll hier alles locker
und privat sein, sagt mir Davis.
Ist das echt so?
(Davis:)
Oder?
Ich glaube, dass da schon
einige Synergien sind,
die man angehen sollte.
Komplett.
(Lauter Jubel)
Ist es jetzt eigentlich eher
so ein Vorteil oder ein Nachteil,
dass du jetzt so jung bist?
Also, es kommt immer
auf die Situation drauf an.
Wenn du ganz am Anfang bist
und deinen Fuß in den Markt noch
nicht wirklich reinkriegen kannst,
ist es natürlich schwierig.
Jetzt mit der Zeit,
wo du aber mehr Leute kennenlernst
und die auch wirklich feiern,
was du machst,
ist es ein unheimlich großer Vorteil,
weil man auffällt.
Was für Leute sind denn
heute hier noch in der Loge?
Letztes mal war hier
beispielsweise ...
von Check24, äh, der ...
(Jubel wird lauter, Pfiff.)
(off:) Was Davis grade sagen wollte,
der Gründer von Check24 war hier.
Das ist so das Level der Leute, mit
denen er jetzt in VIP-Lounges sitzt.
(Lauter Jubel, Grölen, Klatschen)
(Davis, ruft:) Artin! Artin!
Und wenn ich die gegen dein Handy
halte, dann hast du 'n Pop-up
mit allen meinen
Kontaktinformationen.
So, und warte mal ...
(Jubel)
Jetzt verpass ich wieder
das ganze Spiel direkt.
Wollen wir das nachher mal machen?
- Können wir machen.
(off:) Und auch hier wieder:
neue potenzielle Kunden anwerben.
Viele Firmen
haben jetzt Testläufe gemacht.
Wir haben ein paar größere jetzt
als Kunden gewonnen.
Aber so die Riesenfische ...
Da wird das jetzt in Q1
in den Konzern ausgerollt.
Da kommt auch noch einiges dazu.
- Ja.
Ja.
Da.
(Davis:) Super Sache.
Geil, oder?
- Habt ihr gut gemacht.
Ja, safe.
(Stimmengewirr)
Was treibt dich denn genau an,
dir diese ganze Arbeit zuzumuten?
Also, was ich unglaublich
stark finde,
was mir auch sehr am Herzen liegt,
ist, dass man einfach
was auf die Beine stellt,
was auch wirklich von Substanz ist
und auch bestehen bleibt.
Also, ich kann morgen weg sein,
trotzdem hinterlasse ich Spuren.
Und, ähm, das geht auch
in einem noch viel größeren Stil.
(Max:) Wie lang geht's heut noch?
- Artin, wie lang geht's heut noch?
Fragt Max. Im Büro.
- Bis zwei, drei Uhr.
Kann bis zwei, drei Uhr gehen.
Schauen wir mal.
Morgen steht wieder 'ne Menge an.
- Heftig.
Morgen geht die Woche wieder los.
Ja.
(lacht:) So muss das.
Ich hätte vor diesen zwei Tagen
nicht gedacht,
dass Davis die ganze Zeit
so grundentspannt sein wird.
Also, die ganze Zeit
hat sein Telefon geklingelt,
Leute wollten was von ihm.
Das zeigt mir aber auch,
wie sehr er das halt will.
Also, er will alles mitnehmen,
was diese Businesswelt ihm bietet,
und sich da halt auch durchsetzen.
Und das geht nur mit
sehr, sehr viel Arbeit.
Meine Welt wär das nicht.
Könntet ihr euch so ein Leben
für euch vorstellen?
Schreibt das doch gern mal
unten in die Kommentare.
Wenn ihr Bock habt,
dass jede Woche 'ne neue spannende
Reportage von uns
in eurem Feed landet,
dann abonniert gern unseren Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke.
Und Felix,
der trinkt seit sechs Jahren
jeden Tag fünf Dosen Energydrinks.
Ja, man wird ein bisschen hibbelig,
leicht nervös,
bekommt ein bisschen
Schweißausbrüche.
Was das mit Felix' Gesundheit macht,
könnt ihr hier im ganzen Film sehen.
Und da drunter gibt's noch
eine Reportage von "TRU Doku".
Danke euch und bis zum nächsten Mal.
(Dynamische Musik)